sous pression c'est le moment de vérité
pour les dirigeants d'heure qui canada
l'ultime occasion de prouver qu'ils sont
les bonnes personnes pour changer la
culture du silence dans leur
organisation wisches d'anouar el qods
dan warren kole dancing squatters
des excuses pour la gestion de la sphère
d'un viol collectif a légué à london en
ontario en 2018 des promesses de changer
la culture de l'organisation mais pas de
démission
après un témoignage jugé opaque le mois
dernier les dirigeants de hockey canada
tente de faire preuve de transparence
outre la compensation financière pour la
victime alléguée de la sphère de landon
on apprend que depuis 1989 hockey canada
a puisé 7,6 millions de dollars dans un
fonds de réserve pour conclure ne font
autre entente à l'amiable avec des
victimes d'abus sexuels
cela s'ajoute un montant de 1,3 millions
payés par les assurances pour 12 affaire
de nature sexuelle à venir
cet argent n'a pas servi à protéger
notre image se défend le pdg mais bien à
appuyer les victimes or des questions
persistent sur les actions des
dirigeants pourquoi avoir mis fin à l'
enquête sur le viol collectif alléguée
de london en ontario après le versement
d'une compensation à la victime
mettre fin à une enquête
est ce vraiment la façon d'opérer un
changement de culture demande sept
députés scott tim et se défend d'avoir
voulu balayer la sphère sous le tapis
rouge loin d'être convaincu les députés
de l'opposition ont désavoué tour à tour
le grand patron de hockey canada ça
prend un nouveau leadership justement
pour vraiment faire face cet échec total
d'éclat pour moi que l'organisation a
besoin de redorer son blason et faire un
grand ménage vous n'êtes pas habilités
pour pouvoir
mener à bien les changements profonds
qu'on a à faire dans l'ensemble de la
structure d'arqués canada déçu du
témoignage la ministre fédérale des
sports exige aussi des changements à la
tête de hockey canada malgré la
sincérité 2009 il semble avoir encore de
la difficulté à reconnaître les
problèmes systémiques aux fins du canada
le grand patron de hockey canada n'a pas
voulu prononcer les mots crise et
problèmes systémiques lors de son
témoignage pas d'engagement ferme non
plus à faire une meilleure place aux
femmes dans les sphères décisionnelles
parmi les têtes dirigeantes du monde
jura qui réunit autour de la table
aujourd'hui il n'y avait que des hommes
ici louis blouin radio canada ottawa